let's talk about this story we got from
the la times
trial to determine if requiring women on
boards is legal that's our truck so this
is your trial this is a story from uh
back in december but uh you know when
you get a president who says
the principal determinant for a supreme
court nominee is going to be race and
gender i'm like that flies in the face
of the civil rights movement it flies in
the face of what we were fighting for
and it's what the critical race
theorists want
the the cultural left or whatever they
want your position to be determined
determined based on identity
so so in in california what did they do
they passed a law saying that
woman the legislature passed the law
requiring certain that a certain number
of seats be a set aside for women
and so that means that men can't apply
for certain seats on corporate boards of
directors in california
it's outrageously illegal it's a
violation of california constitution
which is even has more broader
protections
uh for against sexual discrimination
than the federal constitution does
and so we've been in court we have four
lawyers out there for six weeks
fighting the government who are bringing
in all these
uh all these so-called experts who are
pretending that it's right to require
women to be on the boards and and
discriminate on the basis of sex and the
argument they're using the left argument
is well it helps corporations to have
more women on the boards you know
there's no real evidence of that but
even if it did it's illegal it's still
illegal it's still legal and but the
point is they're fighting it and so
those of us who
when the left says they're in favor of
and hate discrimination that's the big
lie of our error yeah the the the the
most interesting development and
troubling development is the the
thorough assault
on anti-discrimination law in our
schools and our corporations in our
military
and you see it now in the government
that that you can target people based on
race or sex and discriminate against
them and you'll have all the king's
horses and all king's men i mean we're
in court suing the california state of
california where is the justice
department
where is the justice department the
civil rights division is harassing
states for requiring voter id but
allowing discrimination
based on sex race and every other
category to go on in california with
nary a peep
yeah was trump doing anything about it
listen trump for trump well that just
now but the professional department
under trump was a disaster too i mean
barr had no interest in doing any of
this aggressive thing now i say i say
that knowing that he did do some good
things but the point is the justice
department institutionally is a locus of
evil when it comes to public policy and
they do not believe and this was true in
the obama administration there was an ig
report they didn't believe the laws
against racial discrimination applied
the whites and voting matters
i mean that was that was the finding it
was our people who worked there told us
that we have some employ our attorneys
used to work the justice department they
were told that it's not designed we
don't believe these civil rights laws
will apply to all people we had we had
some guy in the show i'm not gonna say
his name but he was arguing and very
much in favor of critical race theory
and stuff
and you know you know he's saying like
you you guys want to ban this stuff from
schools and blah blah blah
my response to this just simply simply
when when donald trump wanted to ban the
critical race theory trainings for
contractors and stuff like that
and these leftists are like i thought
you supported free speech i'm like uh
yeah i do i do i'm just also in favor of
enforcing laws and if it's an illegal
discriminatory action based on the civil
rights law we enforce it right so you
can't come to me and be like we like the
1964 civil rights act we we like these
rulings it's like oh well trump wants to
enforce it how dare you we should be
allowed to discriminate but you
shouldn't it's like that who's that guy
was it frank herbert was his name when i
am weaker than you i asked for freedom
because it's according to your
principles when when you know why i'm
stronger than you i deny your freedom
because according to mine was that frank
herbert said that that's a good i'm not
sure he looked at a similar version
evil okay cool evil calls for tolerance
until it's ascendant and then it calls
for submission basically but the left is
always you know the left uses these
arguments as a tool exactly and when the
tool becomes
not useful they passed it aside so
anti-anti-discrimination
they saw as a political tool
now they don't like it they cast it
aside the supreme court they liked when
it was roe versus wade but now that
they're ruling against us oh no we gotta
cast it aside right we used to like the
senate filibuster but now we need to
eliminate the senate on top of the
defense yeah that was colbert he said
that right yeah the senate the senate so
when you the the you know like i say
revolutionary moment filibuster isn't
the target the target is eliminating any
impediment
to power
amen stephen colbert goes on his show
with elizabeth warren i think this was a
week ago and he says we should get rid
of the senate and everyone laughs he's
like i'm gonna say this hear me out hear
me out
why don't we abolish the senate the
whole audience laughs and he goes i'm
100 serious
yeah if you're 100 serious and your
audience is laughing at you when you say
it you're insane yeah liz is 100
cherokee yeah he was like actually i'm
like .0019 serious but no it goes to
show you how far these people have gone
because we one thing that we used to say
to make fun of them when they would talk
about the electoral college was that
at that point they may as well just try
to abolish representative government in
general and now they're actually doing
this and i've also seen this with
respect to the argument that's been made
about gun control i've heard a lot of
conservatives say well why not ban
automobiles because of all the people
who die in car accidents and now i'm
actually hearing left-wing people argue
that we need to shift to a national
railway oh yeah never arguments yeah
never never presume the crazy stuff yeah
exactly
yeah yeah exactly so it's like every
single it's like jokes that we will make
to highlight the ridiculousness of their
worldview tend to become positions that
they actually support within a matter of
years
authoritarianism will do that if if
their enemy makes a joke like well here
they come authoritarians would be like
they gave us the green light let's go
well well trump was criticized for
saying that um oh look they're taking
down statues of confederates are they
going to take down statues of jefferson
and washington i remember thinking oh
yes they will yes i mean that's
perfectly i mean we laugh at the
craziness but it's person
perfectly rational within the marxist
world view
and they don't found it funny and
they're perfectly willing to
go to these extreme circumstances i mean
look the january's i call it the rump
committee the january 6 trump committee
is a one-party committee in the house
that is exercising legislative and
investigative power is it actually all
one party well there are republicans who
answer to nancy pelosi but who have not
been who don't represent the minority
party so it's a one-party operation
so how how is that consistent
with a republican form of government no
that should be an external independent
organization doing that committee well
it shouldn't be you know what they're
investigating is their political
opposition i mean that that's when you
talk about the ussr that's the playbook
also speaking of the statutes do you
remember when npr did a fact check on
trump's statement that they would
eventually go after statues of people
like washington and jefferson and they
they fact checked his prediction
before it happened saying it was
incorrect don't get me started on the
fact check they're fantastic
yeah
i used to think that we should get rid
of the republican uh republicanism i
thought the house of representatives is
this is like 2007. i was talking to mike
gravel actually he was an alaskan
senator at the time and i i was able to
communicate with him a little bit and i
thought it's just i saw them getting
bribed i saw the the stop gap of like
only these guys get to make the laws it
just felt like
they were all corrupt i wanted it gone i
was like why can't we just have
the americans pass the laws into the
senate and then let the senate be the
stop gap why do we need this house of
representatives anymore we have internet
and gravel is like no no we need the
house of representatives and i was like
is he just brainwashed because he's from
that system or do we actually need this
i don't know i don't think they should
have the monopoly on on law making
though yeah i mean the founders wanted
kind of a a the republican system is is
is has democratic
uh you know democratic outlooks but it
it it kind of is also designed
to suppress
the sign of the vote by you know just
had the popular vote be promoted
directly so uh so that the passions of
the moment
don't uh result in legislation being
passed everyone gets angry about joe
rogan and he gets banned
because there's this backlash and then
oh what happens the next day well he's
banned because it was passed because
they had a vote that was national that
resulted in getting banned you don't
want to be on the wrong end of that and
when you have
liberties that are protected by law
and are supposed to be protected by law
at all times under a constitution you
don't want to have those subjected to
uh you know the popular passions as well
so
we have a republican form of government
with democratic aspects
and the left hates it we we've had this
conversation before ian where uh i said
all everyone in this room all in favor
of taking ian's stuff from him
yeah
everybody i'm good everybody raise your
hand everyone agrees okay ian give us
your stuff well then you'd have to send
it to the senate and the senate would
look at it and be like uh what's this
insane stuff and who is the person that
tried to pass this in the point is when
you have direct democracy we can just
vote to take from you
i like the senate i'm just saying the
house of representatives i don't
understand the value
they represent the people and the senate
representatives but they don't represent
the people that's the problem they're
supposed to one person represent seven
hundred thousand people whoa whoa whoa
they represent their own interests whoa
ian
750 000 people thank you for the update
yeah this is a lot of people
so they don't and they don't and and
this is something that colbert said when
uh cursing cinema was like the
filibuster
makes sure that legislation has to have
a broad range of support
colbert goes no no
you represent 40 he's like the party
filibustering represents 41 million less
people
colbert thinks
that the 50 percent or the 49 percent of
illinois that are republican or whatever
the number is
just blindly agree
with their senator because the election
was won yeah no that's not how it works
right in fact there's a great deal of
republicans and many of these blue
states who are very very very unhappy so
when colbert is like but you but you
represent more people yeah well those 41
million people are probably
conservatives who don't like you who
don't agree with you so it's not as
simple as just be like do whatever you
want when you get power well i mean
it's it's like this argument about the
popular versus the electoral vote what
the left does is they take numbers
and apply them to a game
that the numbers aren't
that are outside the game's rules
so oh no the yankees really won last
year because they got more strikeouts
than whoever won the world series well
that may be interesting as a matter of
fact
but that's not the way the game was
played and no one played the game to get
more strikes exactly so no one plays the
game in presidential elections to get
more of the popular vote so it's
irrelevant to analysis of who gets more
votes or not yeah and it's the same at
the congressional level in the senate
level it's the popular vote it's not
it's not relevant
to the game like it's an indication
because if one team got like
a hundred times more strikeouts than any
other team but they still didn't win you
might think maybe the game's being
played wrong well for instance trump
doesn't have to
trump doesn't campaign in california
so all that popular vote that's run up
for democrats in california
is never countered because playing the
game doesn't mean repub doesn't means
that republicans don't go and ask for
the popular vote now if there was a
popular vote contest every four years
democrats think they'd win
no the game would change and republicans
would start agitating for the popular
vote and who knows who would win yeah
well well no if they're if there was a
popular if if one day they said hey
everybody guess what 2024 is gonna be
popular vote
it wouldn't just change the rules of the
game the country would be ripped apart
by chaos and fighting through the crew
of course the left doesn't believe in
the popular vote because they want to
change electoral college so let's say
that texas
votes majority for trump but the
majority of electors are voting for
for biden or the popular vote is
different in other states texas has to
ignore their popular vote right yeah
it's it's all a game well and i prefer
the game the founders set out for us
rather than the game the left is trying
to come up with now yeah so the first
time i ever voted was in cook county um
but
how many times did you vote yeah exactly
only once believe it or not but uh i
don't question the legitimacy of cook
county elections i will say this i
remember feeling like it was a protest
vote because it's just such a deep blue
county and illinois such a blue state
that i didn't think it was going to have
any effect so i voted for who i wanted
to but i recognized probably wasn't
going to have an effect and i knew a lot
of people who didn't vote a lot of
conservatives who didn't vote because
they knew the state was going to go blue
i think you're right that if we did
change to a system that was purely based
on the popular vote there actually is a
chance that the republicans would win
because a lot of people who are
disillusioned by the politics of their
local
municipality or state would start voting
that said i agree with you it's not and
it would not be an improvement thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time